The first is hQuery where
the goal is simplicity,
in part by working with a limited data
set that is well standardized because
of its key role in quality measurement
and other common clinical activities.
As you can see here, hQuery provides
an attractive modern point-and-click
interface called the hQuery composer
to the query builder who might even be
a nontechnical health care provider.
At the same time,
the possible queries that can be
formulated are somewhat limited.
HQuery uses a simple patient
information model as shown here
to facilitate query building
by nontechnical users.
Queries are forwarded to an hQuery
gateway located at each source system
which receives them in a standard format
and forwards them to an adapter which
knows how to translate the query for
the source system, which might, for
example, provide a CCDA
document in response and
can convert it into the standard
data model for transmission back.
You should watch a video to learn more.
The URL is in the instructor's notes.
HQuery presents its results
in an attractive way
that in this example includes
a frequency distribution,
a distribution over time, and a
geographic distribution of the results.